>> Juan: PRESIDENT TRUMP
STEERING CLEAR OF POLITICS
IN HIS SALUTE TO AMERICA
FOURTH OF JULY EVENT
YESTERDAY ON THE NATIONAL
MALL.
>> TODAY WE COME TOGETHER AS
ONE NATION WITH THIS VERY
SPECIAL SALUTE TO AMERICA.
WE CELEBRATE OUR HISTORY,
OUR PEOPLE AND THE HEROS WHO
PROUDLY DEFEND OUR FLAG, THE
BRAVE MEN AND WOMEN OF THE
UNITED STATES MILITARY.
[CHEERS]
AS WE GATHER THIS EVENING IN
THE JOY OF FREEDOM WE
REMEMBER THAT ALL SHARE A
TRULY EXTRAORDINARY
HERITAGE.
TOGETHER, WE ARE PART OF ONE
OF THE GREATEST STORIES EVER
TOLD, THE STORY OF AMERICA.
IT IS THE CHRONICLE OF BRAVE
CITIZENS WHO NEVER GIVE UP
ON THE DREAM OF A BETTER AND
BRIGHTER FUTURE.
TO THIS DAY, THAT SPIRIT
RUNS THROUGH THE VEINS OF
EVERY AMERICAN PATRIOT.
IT LIVES ON IN EACH AND
EVERY ONE OF YOU HERE TODAY.
IT IS THE SPIRIT DARING AND
IN DEFIANCE EXCELLENCE IN
ADVENTURE.
COURAGE AND CONFIDENCE.
LOYALTY AND LOVE THAT BUILT
THIS COUNTRY INTO THE MOST
EXCEPTIONAL NATION IN THE
HISTORY OF THE WORLD AND OUR
NATION IS STRONGER TODAY
THAN IT EVER WAS BEFORE.
>> FOR AMERICANS, NOTHING IS
IMPOSSIBLE.
>> Juan: A "THE WASHINGTON
POST" OP-ED WRITER PRAISED
THE PRESIDENT SAYING QUOTE
TRUMP MADE HIS CRITICS LOOK
SMALL DURING THE SALUTE TO
AMERICA UNQUOTE.
BUT 2020 DEMOCRATS THEY
STILL HAD SOME HARSH WORDS
FOR THE EVENT.
>> IT'S BECOME A DAY WHERE
IT'S ALL ABOUT TRUMP RATHER
THAN OUR COUNTRY AND VISION
AND VISION OUR HAD FOR US.
>> IF HE REALLY CARES ABOUT
THE MEN AND WOMEN WHO SERVE
IN OUR NATION HE WOULD BE
INVESTING IN HIGHER PAY,
BETTER HOUSING AND BETTER
HEALTHCARE.
>> I THINK WE NEED MONEY TO
GO INTO AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
I THINK WE NEED MONEY TO GO
INTO REBUILDING OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE.
I'M NOT QUITE SURE WE NEED
MONEY TO GO IN TO PUT TANKS
IN DOWNTOWN WASHINGTON, D.C.
>> DONALD TRUMP IS HANDING
OUT TICKETS TO HIS BIG
DONORS.
THAT'S A CAMPAIGN EVENT.
AND IF HE IS GOING TO DO A
CAMPAIGN EVENT, THEN IT
SHOULD BE PAID FOR BY HIS
CAMPAIGN CONVICTIONS.
IT SHOULD NOT BE PAID FOR BY
THE AMERICAN TAXPAYER.
>> Juan: ANNA KOOIMAN, GOOD
TO SEE YOU.
>> GREAT TO SEE YOU TOO.
>> Juan: YOU KNOW WE LOVE
YOU HERE AT FOX.
AN AN HAPPY TO BE BACK.
FIRST TIME ON "THE FIVE."
GOOD TO BE HERE.
>> Juan: DID YOU SEE IT.
>> OF COURSE I DID.
I ACTUALLY WAS WATCHING FROM
AN AIRPLANE.
I WAS HEADING BACK FROM
CHARLESTON, SOUTH CAROLINA
AFTER DOING OUR PROUD
AMERICAN COVERAGE THERE AND
FEELING EXTRA PATRIOTIC ON
THE HEELS OF THAT ANYWAY.
I THOUGHT I WAS HAVING A
SPIRITUAL EXPERIENCE.
IF YOU ARE AN AMERICAN
WATCHING THIS AND DOESN'T
MATTER HOW YOU FELT ABOUT
THE PRESIDENT BEFORE THIS
SPEECH, IT WAS 3W50U68 AND
INCREDIBLE.
THE DEMOCRATS YOU STLAWT
DEMOCRATS SAYING HE IS JUST
DOING THIS FOR HIMSELF.
IS HE THROWING HIMSELF A
PARADE.
HE DIDN'T SAY ANYTHING ABOUT
HIMSELF.
HE SPOKE ABOUT DECORATED
MILITARY VETERANS.
HE TALKED ABOUT ASTRONAUTS.
HE TALKED ABOUT CIVIL RIGHTS
LEADERS.
HE TALKED ABOUT AMERICAN
EXCEPTIONALISM, HE PUT
POLITICS ASIDE FOR THIS.
I WAS IMPRESSED.
YOU REMEMBER WHEN HE WAS ON
THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL IN 2016
AND HE SAID I'M GOING TO BE
SO PRESIDENTIAL WHEN I WANT
TO BE I WILL BE BORING.
HE WASN'T BORING HE
CERTAINLY WAS PRESIDENTIAL.
HE LEFT HIS SLINGS AND
ARROWS FOR ANOTHER DAY.
I THOUGHT IT WAS PERFECT AND
HAD THE PERFECT TONE.
>> Juan: ONE OF THE CRITICS
MOCK HIM FOR SAYING
COINCIDENTAL ARMY WAS GOING
TO AN AIRPORT CLEARING OUT
AN AIRPORT.
I WANT TO GIVE HIM THE
BENEFIT OF THE DOUBT.
I KNOW A LOT OF PEOPLE
DIDN'T GIVE OBAMA THE
BENEFIT OF THE DOUBT WHEN HE
SAID 57 STATES WHEN HE WAS
CAMPAIGNING.
I'M GOING TO GIVE THE
PRESIDENT THE BENEFIT OF THE
DOUBT.
>> LOOK AT YOU, JUAN.
>> Juan: FOURTH OF JULY.
WHAT DID YOU THINK?
>> WELL, I THINK THAT HIS
CRITICS LOOKED PRETTY DUMB
YESTERDAY.
ALL OF THEM THAT SAID THAT
THIS WAS GOING TO BE A TRUMP
CAMPAIGN RALLY, HAVE Y'ALL
BEEN TO A TRUMP CAMPAIGN
RALLY THAT WAS NOTHING LIKE
A TRUMP CAMPAIGN RALLY.
THEY TALK ABOUT MULTIPLE
THINGS.
THE CROWD IS MUCH ROWDIER
AND TRUMP TALKED ABOUT
HIMSELF AND NOT AMERICA AND
HIS GREATNESS AS WELL.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT SHOWED
THAT HE WAS PIG TO PUT
POLITICS ASIDE AND TALK
ABOUT WHAT'S BETTS FOR THE
COUNTRY AND HOW TO MOVE
FORWARD.
A LOT OF PEOPLE SAID IT WAS
BORING BECAUSE HE GAVE A
HISTORY LESSON.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
WE REMEMBER OUR HISTORY SO
WE DON'T REPEAT IT AS WELL
THERE WERE SOME CRITICS THAT
TALKED ABOUT THE MILITARY
AND THE PRESIDENT FLEXING
WHEN IT CAME TO SHOWING OUR
GREAT MILITARY.
LOOK, THIS HAS BEEN A
PRESIDENT THAT HAS BEEN VERY
RESTRAINED WHEN IT COMES TO
MILITARY FORCE.
SO IF HE WANTS TO FLEX TO
SHOW THE WORLD THIS IS HOW
YOU DEFEND FREEDOM.
THIS IS WHAT WE HAVE TO
OFFER, I THINK THAT IS TO BE
APPLAUDED INSTEAD OF SENDING
OUR MILITARY INTO HARM'S
WAY.
>> Juan: ALL RIGHT.
SO, TAMMY, LET ME GET
SERIOUS WITH YOU FOR JUST A
SECOND.
>> Tammy: NO.
ALL RIGHT.
>> Juan: YOU WHAT YOU
ELIZABETH WARREN SAID THERE
HE DIDN'T HAVE HIS DONORS
PAY FOR THIS EVENT EVEN
THOUGH THEY HAD RESERVED
SEATING AND TICKETS.
HE COULD HAVE AND I'M SURE
SOME OF THEM WOULD HAVE PAID
FOR IT.
INSTEAD IT WAS THE U.S. PARK
SERVICE THAT WENT, YOU KNOW,
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS, TAKEN
OUT OF THEIR BUDGET.
BUDGET MONEY THAT COULD HAVE
GONE TO PARKS OR HELPING
YOUNG PEOPLE TO GO TO VISIT
PARKS.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THAT?
>> Tammy: YOU KNOW, WHEN YOU
WIN THE PRESIDENCY THERE ARE
BENEFITS TO THAT, RIGHT?
YOU ALSO INVITE PEOPLE TO
THE WHITE HOUSE WHO
SUPPORTED YOU AND ARE YOUR
SUPPORTERS.
THAT'S PART OF THE NATURAL
PROCESS HEEMPLE THE NATURAL
PARKS SERVICE WE HAD ABOUT
$2.25 MILLION NOBODY WAS
CLUTCHING THEIR PEARLS IN
2016 WHEN THE NATIONAL PARK
SERVICE SPENT $30 MILLION
FOR THEIR OWN 100 YEAR
ANNIVERSARY.
AND, I THINK ALL OF THAT IS
A DISTRACTION.
I THINK WHAT HAVE YOU GOT
HERE WORRYING ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT TALKING ABOUT
HIMSELF, THERE IS ONLY ONE
GROUP OF PEOPLE TALKING
CONSTANTLY ABOUT DONALD
TRUMP.
AND IT'S THE DEMOCRATS.
HE IS STILL IN THE BUILDING
MODE.
HE HAS CONDOMINIUMS IN THEIR
HEAD AND IT'S THE MOST
AFFORDABLE LIVING SITUATION.
BERNIE SANDERS WANTS
AFFORDABLE LIVING, HE IS
LIVING IN THEIR HEADS FOR
FREE.
THERE IS NO RENT.
I THINK THERE IS A LOFT
PROJECTION GOING ON.
HE IS THE CENTER OF THEIR
UNIVERSE.
YOU MAY DISAGREE WITH THIS,
BUT TOUGH ADMIT.
THEY THINK THEY ARE GOING TO
WIN THE PRESIDENCY BASED ON
OBSESSING ABOUT DONALD
TRUMP.
MAYBE YOU HAVE CHANGED A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED YESTERDAY.
THEY ARE AFRAID THAT AS THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE WATCH
SOMETHING LIKE THAT, PEOPLE
ARE TRANSFORMED AND REALIZE
THAT THEY HAVE BEEN LIED TO
FOR THE PAST THREE YEARS
ABOUT THIS MAN.
>> Juan: YOU THINK IT WOULD
PERSUADE PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT
PRO-TRUMP.
>> I THINK.
SO WE HAVE ALREADY SEEN IT.
WHEN PEOPLE -- WITH THE
MUELLER REPORT AS AN
EXAMPLE.
AFTER ALL THE STUFF WITH CNN
AND IT WAS NOT WHAT THEY
SAID IT WAS GOING TO BE,
ALREADY PEOPLE HAVE REALIZED
THEY HAVE BEEN LIED TO ABOUT
SERIOUS ISSUES.
THEY HAVE RETREATED, YOU
KNOW, WHEN IT COMES TO
RATINGS AND WHO THEY ARE
LISTENING.
TO SAY THAT'S A SIGN THAT
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WANT THE
TRUTH, THEY WANT
INFORMATION, AND THEY ARE
TIRED OF BEING LIED.
TO SAY.
>> Juan: I DISAGREE.
I LOVE THE FOURTH OF JULY.
AND I JUST DIDN'T WANT
POLITICS BROUGHT IN.
>> Lawrence: IF HE WOULD
HAVE PAID THE MONEY WOULD IT
BE OVER?
>> Juan: WELCOME, BY THE WAY
FIRST TIME YOU ARE SITTING
ON THIS SET.
>> Jon: I KNOW.
VERY COOL.
>> Juan: YOU ARE WELCOME.
THANK YOU FOR COMING TODAY.
JOHN, LET'S GO BEYOND
POLITICS FOR A SECOND.
WHAT DID YOU THINK AS A
CULTURAL ABOUT THE EVENT?
>> JOHN: THE MEN AND WOMEN
WHO SERVE IN OUR MILITARY
ARE NOT DEMOCRATS OR
REPUBLICANS OR INDEPENDENCE.
THEY ARE EVERYBODY THAT
SERVES IN THE MILITARY.
I THINK HONESTLY THE
PRESIDENT DID A GREAT
SERVICE TO THE MILITARY IN
RESPECTING THAT FACT AND NOT
GOING INTO A PARTISAN ANGLE
WHEN HE WAS WATCHING.
I WATCHED THE ENTIRE THING.
I KEPT WAITING FOR HIM TO GO
HARD TO HIS BASE OR
WHATEVER, AND HE NEVER DID
IT.
I MEAN I HEARD EVERYBODY
FROM JACQUE ROBINSON TO JOHN
GLENN TALKED ABOUT IN THESE
SPEECHES.
AND EVEN FOR ME THESE NAMES
START COMING UP.
AND YOU REMEMBER THESE
POWERFUL, POWERFUL AMERICANS
AND ENTREPRENEURS AND GREAT
TALENTS THAT ONLY COULD HAVE
SUCCEEDED LIKE THAT HAD THEY
LIVED IN OUR COUNTRY AND
MILITARY AS STRONG AS OURS
TO PROTECT THEIR RIGHT TO
BECOME GREAT BASEBALL
PLAYERS OR ASTRONAUTS OR
ACTORS OR ALL THE GREAT
PEOPLE HE WAS NAMING.
I THOUGHT HE DID A GREAT JOB
BY SAYING RIGHT ON THE
MESSAGE.
TO SAY ME IT WAS ALMOST LIKE
A HISTORY LESSON A REFRESHER
COURSE GOING THROUGH EVERY
SINGLE BRANCH OF THE
MILITARY.
POINTING OUT GREAT PEOPLE
THAT DO GREAT THINGS.
HERE COMES THE ACTUAL
HARDWARE.
FLYING RIGHT OVER THE TOP OF
THE WASHINGTON MONUMENT AND
YOU ARE LIKE WOW.
I MEAN, I THINK FOR
AMERICANS, FOR ME IT WAS A
MOMENT OF PRIDE TO SEE ALL
OF THAT COME TOGETHER IN ONE
MOMENT.
AND ALSO, I THINK AROUND THE
WORLD, THEY ARE WATCHING
THAT GOING YEAH, THEY HAVE
GOT -- AMERICA IS NO JOKE.
AND LOOK AT HOW OUR
PRINCIPLES OF THIS COUNTRY
HAVE DEVELOPED SO MANY
INCREDIBLE AMERICANS.
WE INVENTED ROCK AND ROLL
AND COUNTRY MUSIC AND R AND
B AND THE AUTOMOBILE ALL THE
THINGS HE STARTED REMINDING
US UP.
>> JAZZ.
>> REMINDS YOU HOW GREAT OUR
COUNTRY IS AND IT'S GREAT
BECAUSE IT'S FREE.
>> Juan: I THINK HE SAID
ALEXANDER GRAHAM BELLE BUT
THE CANADIANS SAID IT WAS
THE CANADIANS.
>> Tammy: WHAT WAS THE
PRESIDENT GOING TO DO HE HAD
A GREAT SPEECH AT NORMANDY.
HIS STATE OF THE UNION
ADDRESSES HAVE BEEN
UNIVERSALLY PRAISED.
THIS IS NOT A SURPRISE.
AND, AS YOU HAVE SAID, HE
SAID I'M GOING TO BE
PRESIDENTIAL.
PEOPLE CONTINUE TO UNDER
ESTIMATE HIM AND THIS IS WHY
THEY GET BLIND SIDED.
>> Juan: ANNA, YOU WERE
GOING TO MAKE A POINT.
>> I WAS GOING TO SAY IT
REALLY DELEGITIMIZES THE
CABLE NETWORKS WHEN THEY
COME OUT WITH KNIVES FOR
TRUMP AT A TIME WHEN HE IS
CLEARLY KNOCKING IT OUT OF
THE PARK, RIGHT?
I THINK, OF COURSE WE AIRED
IT.
I WAS FLIPPING BACK AND
FORTH BETWEEN US AND CNN
SINCE IT'S PART OF MY JOB
OKAY HOW ARE THEY COVERING
IT?
I JUST -- I THINK THEY
REALLY MISSED THE MARK.